[Musique]
bon sang mais à mon sens mesdemoiselles
bonsoir messieurs c'est un masque et la
plume un peu spécial que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui est un masque et
la plume plus court puisque la soirée du
1er de l'an est un peu chargé
nous n'aurons pas une tribune de
critiques comme d'habitude nous n'aurons
qu'un invité s'est invitée c'est à jeune
metteur en scène un jeune et très
célèbre metteur en scène que les
auditeurs du masque et la plume
connaissent particulièrement bien que
notre speaker inc lauder valve a annoncé
voici notre invité françois truffaut
françois truffaut ce n'est pas pour
parler d'un film encore que j'aurais
bien aimé vous entendre parler de
fahrenheit dont certains de nos
critiques on dit beaucoup de bien
d'autres un autre un peu moins de biens
et moi si ça peut avoir une importance
quelconque beaucoup plus est un film que
j'aime énormément que j'ai vu deux fois
ce qui m'arrive rarement c'est pas pour
parler d'un film et pour parler d'un
livre d'un énorme ligne que vous venez
de publier et qui est un livre
passionnant à condition peut-être de
s'intéresser à hitchcock puisque
s'appelle le cinéma selon hitchcock mais
pas seulement cela parce que à ma
connaissance c'est la première fois
qu'un metteur en scène de cinéma plus
jeunes posent quoi 500 questions je
crois un grand metteur en scène de
cinéma et que tous deux parlent du
cinéma non pas comme des critiques ni
comme des grands mancier ni comme des
comédiens mais vraiment comme deux
caméras qui parlent de leur boulot avec
une précision une simplicité en même
temps une absence totale de ce jargon
qui fait ce jargon cinéphilique qui qui
personnellement me fait fuir et là c'est
vraiment d'une limpidité absolue
répression même à chaque instant que
qu'on pourrait presque tourné un film si
on si on n en est rien je sais c'est ça
a l'air simple comme ça vous vous
démontez bien le mécanisme et je n'ai
pas tout lu je m'empresse de vous le
dire il faut beaucoup de temps pour lire
ce livre considérablement illustrait qui
est un beau cadeau à faire à quelqu'un
qui aime le cinéma je n'ai pas tout lu
parce que je n'ai pas vu tous les films
de hitchcock j'en ai vu peut-être dix ou
douze il en a fait je crois 50 50 50
j'aimerais d'abord savoir où que vous
disiez parce que je le cio lui votre
introduction
comment cela s'est passé comment
avez-vous eu l'idée de cette fantastique
entreprise avec hitchcock
j'étais frappé je crois chaque fois je
lisais une interview du scot
j'ai été frappé par son souci de ne rien
dire d'importants de ceux de se tenir
dans les limites de la plaisanterie de
faire des blagues et puis c'était
frappés par ce contraste d'un homme
qui donnait une image publique de lui
s'y opposer à ces films que je trouvais
grave admirable et plaint d'une séance
de cinéma
j'étais persuadé qu'on devait qu'on
pouvait arriver à le convaincre de
parler sérieusement de cinéma oui mais à
priori c'est pas c'est pas tellement un
parent qu'on peut vous donner il tutoie
qu'on ne voit pas a priori les rapports
entre votre rêve est la sienne
votre est vrai plein de enfin je sais
pas si je vais appeler des mots qui vont
peut-être vous déplaire mais enfin est
une oeuvre plus affective disons
hitchcock ont il n'y a pas tellement de
rapports ces pass ait cox et c'est un
monde bien à lui tout ce qu'il fait mais
je crois qu'il est le parrain de tous
les cinéastes parce qu'il est celui qui
s'est le mieux raconter une histoire
si bien que quand même même dans des
mêmes en faisant des films qui ne
contiennent aucun suspens par exemple en
faisant des films semblent sans la mort
ce qui est très rare pour hitchcock
puisque la mort et dans tous les films
d'hitchcock
eh bien il ya toujours un moment où on a
une chose difficile à faire et on se on
ne sait plus très bien comment faire et
je crois qu'on peut arriver si on pense
à eux quand ni comment french cup et ont
je crois que ça peut aider à trouver ça
serait un excitant stimulate un
stimulateur puissant parce que vous
dites à un moment donné dans votre
préface vous donnez une espèce de petite
scène enfin comme ça un monsieur qui
regarde une dame etc et vous analyser la
façon dont x coq le fait et vous pensez
vous dites je crois aucun cinéaste
d'hollywood à cinecitta
aucun autre cinéaste que hitchcock est
actuellement capable de filmer la
réalité humaine de cette scène comme je
lé décrite l'asean et en élémentaire
monsieur y racontera trois personnes des
vacances qui vient de passer en écosse
avec sa femme
et pendant ce temps on regarde les
jambes de madame x et on s'approche de
madame x et on détaille l'élégante
silhouette de la jeune demoiselle z
alors quand j'ai lu ça
malgré mon admiration pour hitchcock et
ma confiance et mon admiration pour vous
ma confiance en vous j'ai eu envie de
contester ce que vous disiez là je dis
quand même il va un peu fort j'imagine
que bergman ou antonioni ou fellini ou
bresson pourrait très bien
montrez ce désir physique de monsieur y
ont madame x et ses jambes de madame z
etc
non non il ne montreront pas
indépendamment du texte les personnages
dans leurs films d'iran véhiculeront un
dialogue qui nous servira à comprendre
ses sentiments tandis qu'ils coque sera
faire une saura faire jouer la seconde
situation purement visuel est en
contradiction avec la première situation
qui sera un dialogue banal c'est à dire
vous savez sentir dans une salle tiens
il est en train de lui mentir tiens il
est en train de se dire qu'il va
peut-être le tuer eh bien il ya que
devant les films d'hitchcock qu'on peut
dire des choses comme ça parce que dans
les autres c'est le dialogue qui vous le
dit tout ou votre livre d'ailleurs tend
à montrer la supériorité du si j'ose
dire dû montrer sur le dit oui à montrer
que le montrer en fait ce qui est montré
et en vraiment la chose importante au
cinéma et hitchcock ne cesse d'en ca à
plusieurs reprises jean neige est notée
au moins trois fois où il dit que
lorsqu'on raconte une histoire ou au
cinéma si on a besoin du dialogue c'est
vraiment on ne sait rien faire ou à peu
près oui c'est pas ta ferme à face et ça
c'est un grand esprit visuel parce que
son esprit s'est formé entre 1924 et
1930 c'est à dire juste avant qu'on
invente le parlant il était arrivé à
être avoir une très grande sciences du
cinéma
juste avant cette invention ce qui lui a
permis d'utiliser le parlant comme 1,1
point au lieu de d'en avoir n'est besoin
de a à z pour raconter on vous dit c'est
pas tout à fait ça je vous demande
pardon mais hitchcock dit lorsqu'on
raconte une histoire au cinéma on ne
devrait recourir au dialogue que
lorsqu'il est impossible de faire
autrement
c'est ça oui l'idée que le dialogue
devrait être une musique doit être une
région plus qu'on peut tout comprendre
par là que vous pensez cela aussi pas
pour tous les films non qu'est-ce que ça
je le pense pour le cinéma d'hitchcock
mais je serai moins
intolérante lui pour la bonne raison que
c'est une chose qui lui appartient à lui
alors j'aime aussi les films de j'aime
aussi des films de dialogue comme les
films de bergman ou les films de fellini
oui mais enfin il scop dans son jules et
jim hoey a tout même les dialogues sans
l'udc sans lequel révéler ce qui t'a
film de texte l'émotion ne pourrait pas
ne pouvez pas ne pourrait pas passer
mais quand même le l'excitation don
quichotte vous donne ses 7 vous à
communiquer certainement car on écrit
par on se donne pas ce travail qui est
fantastique travail d'abord parce que
vous ne peut-être parler vous ne parlez
peut-être pas l'anglais comme hitchcock
qui ne font pas de français comme vous
comment avez vous fait pour que muni cet
effet à trois personnes avec une dame
qui traduisait simultanément comme à
l'unesco et avec des avec des micros
autour du cou et des conversations du
matin jusqu'au soir pendant une dizaine
de jours la mairie en amérique chat
durer des jours et des jours à hollywood
une dizaine de jours et alors hitchcock
ce qui est très frappant là dedans donne
avec une générosité extraordinaire des
tas d'idées de gags ou des idées même
deux scénarios qu'il n'a pas réalisé
oui c'est la première fois je me suis
dit en lisant ça mon dieu jamais un
écrivain et je les connais mieux que les
hélas que les hommes de cinéma ou les
compositeurs jamais un écrivain ne
ferais ça n'est ce pas il vous dira
jamais j'avais pensé un moment dans mon
livre en compte et à l'histoire mais je
ne vais pas fait parce que s'ils gardent
ça pourra toujours me servir tandis que
monsieur hitchcock il vous dit vous
savez où ce oui je pensais faire il ya
des trucs fantastiques comme une
histoire de chêne d'automobiles a admis
ravi 3 2 gars vous dites à un moment
donné également dans votre livre que un
film de hitchcock c'est souvent un
presque toujours un échange de meurtre
qu'est ce que vous entendez par non il a
construit beaucoup de films sur le
principe de l'échangé demeure c'est à
dire quelqu'un
ce qui ne tue pas quelqu'un qui tue une
personne avec laquelle il n'a aucun
rapport et dont il n'est pas pour un
crime dont il ne sera pas le
bénéficiaire et en échange de quoi une
autre personne tuera voilà c'est le
principe de cinq ou six de ses films
mais pas de tous pas de tous non non pas
de tous
mais enfin le principe général de ses
films c'est que le caractère principal
la figure principale est celle d'un
d'innocents accusé injustement
quelqu'un disait un jour de hitchcock il
était à sophistiquer barbares sûr de
vous citer le propos mais je ne sais pas
de qui de kiel et sophistiquée barbares
où une journaliste anglaise originale
anglaise bon il y assure la liaison sur
le sexe pour aller plus vite dans
l'oeuvre de hitchcock des choses très
passionnante quand il parle de quand il
oppose une brigitte bardot et une grèce
qu'elle y va quand pour lui bardot est
moins bonne
by etienne que grace kelly parce qu'elle
a le sexe sur la figure sadie harris
kelly et qu'il dit le sexe est indirect
enfin c'est ça ouais c'est une idée qui
est intéressant d'ailleurs et qui va
pour lui dans le même sens que le
suspens et que si l'héroïne est très
extérieurement charnelle et bien il n'y
a pas de suspense parce que on sait
qu'elle est fait pour l'amour tandis que
si elle al'air froide assez glacial
comme une institutrice anglaise où comme
dans nordiques et bien le moment du
baiser sera un moment très fort dans
l'histoire et ça je crois que les filles
lui ont donné raison là dessus parce
qu'il a eu vraiment beaucoup de très
belle femme blonde et faussement froides
à traverser quel est pour vous le le
plus beau film de hitchcock sur windows
windows windows c'est celui que je
préfère voir ce que vraiment c'est le
sel plus simple et c'est celui qui l'est
qui est le plus de lui c'est à dire donc
peut pas on ne peut pas imaginer rear
window fait par quelqu'un d'autre parce
que c'est justement l'illustration de
cette idée du cinéma purement visuel un
homme paralysé a paralysé avec la jambe
dans le plâtre à une fenêtre et qu'ils
regardent en face des différents
comportements et ses différents
comportements illustrant le même
problème qui est le sien c'est-à-dire le
problème amoureux et en même temps là
vi nations progressive d'un meurtre qui
s'est produit en face et la résolution
de cette énigme je crois que c'est
vraiment une chose qui est absolument
parfaite la wii tout point de vue là la
scène de fenêtres sur coup enfin l'année
de la scène d'exposition de deux
fenêtres sur courts je me souviens quand
je les ai vus en tout cas je n'ai vu
avec un autre plumitifs dans mon genre
plus ou moins romancier qu'en sortant de
nous sommes dit ben ça on pourra jamais
ses bas possible en si peu de temps
faire comprendre que ce monsieur s'est
cassé la jambe que qu'il est photographe
de course automobile c'est ça la fait
rire ou les tâches équipe qui a une
femme qui est amoureux qui est amoureuse
de lui tout ça il ya quand il regarde
les gens d'en face tout ça dure je ne
sais pas combien de temps cinéma une
minute et demie par là oui c'est assez
c'est assez prodigieuse c'est un autre
travail que le roman oui c'est vraiment
un autre travail enfin il ya cette cour
comme ça qui s'éveille c'est le lever du
jour
la caméra se promène passe sur un
thermomètre qui nous indique la chaleur
on est en été il fait très chaud
la fenêtre est ouverte on arrive sur le
visage de cet homme en sueur et on a sa
jambe dans le plâtre il dort encore sur
le mur il y à une photo d'accidents de
voiture et ça c'est très astucieux de
suggérer qu'il ça suggère à la fois
qu'ils y reporter et qu'il a eu un
accident du travail
mais alors que ces fours il pourra voir
une photo pour une autre raison d une
pile de magazines qui nous indique qu'il
travaille pour des magazines américains
oui oui c'est des appareils lavieu
filiale appareils kc un appareil cas
c'est absolument sans raison et aussi
parce que par raison que un jour il a eu
cet accident on amène l'appareil là chez
lui mais enfin tout ça et qui est
arbitraire
ni sur le moment ne paraît pas
arbitraire et nous donne une quantité
d'informations de queuleu qui
permettront aux dialogues ensuite d'être
beaucoup plus direct est beaucoup plus
léger mais alors il ya un moment où je
me suis demandée il est vrai je n'y
connais pas grand chose mais vous allez
me de m'expliquer alors il probablement
à d'autres spectateurs ou d'autres
auditeurs ya un moment vous dites que
beaucoup de gens prétendent que vos
films dits doux à hitchcock son plein
d'effets gratuits et je crois au
contraire que votre travail de caméras
de temps à devenir invisible et on voit
souvent des films dans lesquels le
metteur en scène croit faire du beach
coque en plaçant la caméra des endroits
bizarres et vous citez un film de d'un
metteur en scène anglais dans lequel la
vedette à les prendre quelque chose dans
le réfrigérateur et comme par hasard la
caméra se trouvaient à l'intérieur à la
place de la cloison avait enlevé la
cloison l'ami la caméra dedans point
qu'on est bon voilà une chose que vous
ne feriez jamais non dites vous à
hitchcock il répond non comme de placer
la caméra dans une cheminée
derrière les flammes et alors le le pas
l'amateur que je suis le monsieur qui va
au cinéma je me suis gratter la tête et
je me dis mais pourquoi est-ce mal de
faire ça parce que moi tout bêtement si
vous me donniez une caméra ne me la
donnez jamais s'il y avait un objet
important à prendre dans un
réfrigérateur en effet ce qu'il faut
dire que serait cette offre est
important que ma revolver par exemple
qui joue un rôle dans le film et je rue
en effet tendance à dire à mon
décorateur va enlever mois le fond puis
je mettre à cannes europe comme ça je
verrai la mince avance et c est pourquoi
est-ce que c'est mal au bas je crois
passe comme ça qu on fasse et non mais à
ce moment là toute la symbiose
non c'est une vraiment une raison
d'efficacité c'est toute la salle
devient cinéaste à ce moment là toute la
salle pense la caméra c'est ça c'est
l'idée c'est de ne pas on ne doit pas
faire penser dire si ce sont des lois
enfin je sais pas c'est l'instinct
commandes ces choses là mais on voit
surtout à la télévision la télévision
montrent assez bien presque tous les
soirs ce qu'il ne faut pas faire alors
la télévision nous montre souvent un
homme seul dans une cave par exemple et
la caméra se promène comme ça derrière
des poutres bien on se dit tiens c'est
un autre homme qui l'observent vous
voyez on se trompe
alors nous en fait il est tout seul donc
cette caméra devrait rester fixé de il
faudra une caméra fixe et oui euh
très près de l'homme et ne jamais avoir
de masques entre mellon le si l'homme se
balade alors comment à bassan peu
panoramique et mais enfin il faut de ne
pas sentir si vous voulez il faut pas
passer derrière ce micro il faut pas
sentir une présence parce qu'à ce moment
là on sera tenté de l'attribuer à
quelqu'un qui surveille à quelqu'un qui
regarde oui des choses comme ça je crois
oui et pas ya un autre truc aussi parce
que c'est plein d'astuces de genre si
cela ne nuit pas les sévillans il faut
adorer le cinéma et moi je les aime
beaucoup mais je n'y connais rien il ya
une autre chose aussi qui m'a beaucoup
frappé vous citez ce qu'est ce que tu
n'es qu'une bille d'expérience qu'avait
fait le maître de poudre fine leaf ou
les coulées chauffe ça consistait à
montrer un gros plans vivant mosjoukine
puis à lui faire succéder le plan d'un
bébé mort alors sur le visage de moscou
qui n'en voyaient évidemment une la
compassion pour ce bébé mort au montage
on enlève le plan du bébé mort et on le
remplace par une assiette de nourriture
et sur le plan sur le gros plans de pose
ou king qu'on a tourné pour devant le
bébé mort on lit maintenant l'appétit
n'est ce pas mais cette expérience est
vraiment valable comme on dit
aujourd'hui à la fête oui elle a été
fait vous paraît une chose faisable
allait elle est encore plus valable
aujourd'hui enfin là était faite
autrefois pour montrer que le cinéma
qu'au cinéma ce n'est pas l'expression
de l'acteur qui est importante ce n'est
pas lui que l'expression d'un porte de
l'acteur sera moins importante que le
choc des plans entre alors le même plan
neutre d'un acteur selon qu'on lui fait
succéder effectivement
une assiette bien garnie où un bébé mort
ou une femme nue sur le mur d'en face et
bien ça ça exprime la compassion ou
l'appétit ou l'envi sexuel voilà même la
couleur verte y est on peut intervertir
et je crois justement moi c'est aussi ce
qui m'avait frappé dans les films
d'hitchcock par exemple ce film
s'appelle vertigo jeune steward suit
pendant des heures en voiture kim novak
c'est que je me disais au fond il est là
au volant de sa voiture il ne conduit
pas il n'y a pas de paysages derrière le
paysage a été rajouté après coup donc
cet homme james stewart est venu pendant
huit jours au studio faire ça devant un
fond bleu et tout ce qui le tout ce
qu'il est censé voir a été fait après et
même tout le paysage qui est dernière
lui a été rajouté après la défection un
très très grand comédien sans que ce
soit un comédien formidable et puis
qu'ils sachent que on peut faire
confiance à hitchcock parce que c'est
absurde a joué c'est le contraire de
jouer une pièce c'est le contraire de
d'un personnage à défendre quoi il est
simplement venue prêter sa figure son
visage pendant x temps et il a fait la
même chose dans fenêtre sur cour qu'est
ce qu'il a fait on a dû faire 200 gros
plan de lui à la fenêtre et puis après
on lui a dit rentrez chez vous et puis
on a filmé tout ce qui se passait en
face et plus cette mosaïque est venu et
il n'y a même pas eu si j'ai bien
compris oui je crois qu'il n'y a pas eu
un seul plan d'ensemble de la de l'agglo
en principe non peut-être un plan avec
une amorce de lui une fois mais à part
exceptionnellement dans le film c'est un
autre c'est une autre façon d'envisager
le cinéma c'est l'idée de cette unité
d'assemblage comme dans un tableau de
claix enfin cette unité d'assemblage de
mais sert pas du tout votre façon de
travailler avoue que quelquefois pour
certaines scènes de la vie de certains
films c'est les expériences que valve
votre votre car ça vous avez fait ça y
étudia à vous l'avez vous avez fait ce
travail à des deux en un temps où il
était à ce livre a été les premiers
enregistrements lieu il ya quatre ans
au mois d'août 62 et avant de narrer
night oui j'aimerais juste après gym et
puis je les ai revus chaque année pour
actualiser livre et le temps perdu si le
livre n'est pas paru depuis quatre ans
et que j'ai couru après les photos
partout dans le monde parce que pour que
le livre soit concret et facile à
comprendre il fallait surtout illustré
chaque fois car oui c'est ça qui est
passionnant c'est qu'on est on est on
est à aucun moment perdu même si on n'a
pas vu tous les films qu'on peut se
faire une idée parce c'est vraiment un
livre de cinéaste il ya aussi une
théorie à l'intérieur de ce livre enfin
une des nombreuses théories de hitchcock
qui est particulièrement savoureux c'est
celle qu'il appelle je crois la théorie
du chocolat en suisse et des moulins
hollande et des automobiles à à detroit
et c qui n'est pas le réalisme c'est un
devoir quand il y est expliqué un peu ma
vie c'est l'idée de tout le temps
d'enrichir que la composition doit être
riche et plein et alors il dit si nous
tournons un film en suisse bien
évidemment notre première réaction doit
être de dire qu'est ce qu'ils ont en
suisse ils ont le mont blanc ils ont le
chocolat alors évidemment les espions
travailleront dans une usine de chocolat
avec des fausses blouses blanches etc et
les alpes puisqu'elles sont là et bien
servir on a précipité les gens dans des
crevasses c'est à dire que tout le
matériel d'espionnage tout le matériel
dramatique qu'il utiliserait de toute
façon devra être là en relation avec le
l'endroit de même que à marrakech pour
l'homme qui en savait trop on fera jouer
les indigènes on fera ouvrir le film sur
un scandale c'est l'enfant qui a tiré le
machin blanc d'indigènes dans l'autocar
et voilà ça c'est son principe et quand
il est venu tourner un film évidemment à
nice il a fait la poursuite sur la
grande corniche là pour la main au
collet sont des choses naturelles qui
sont auquel tout le monde pense pas mais
qui sont un tour d'esprit je reviens au
problème du dialogue parce que j'ai par
trouver la phrase tout à l'heure
hitchcock dit pour moi le péché capital
d'un scénariste
c'est lorsqu'on discute une difficulté
d'escamoter le problème en disant nous
justifieront cela par une ligne de
dialogue le dialogue doit être un bruit
parmi les eaux
et ces voix là oui ça c'est très vrai
c'est vraiment une solution de paresse
quand on dit dans un camp vous
travaillez quand on fait même pas où
apparaît un film et que vous avez un
problème ou et que vous vous dites vous
ou que votre collaborateur vous dit baba
on expliquera sa passe qui lui dira
alors que à lui répondre alors que oui
ça va passer le oui parce que cette
phrase a sera forcément mauvaises on
peut avoir aussi du bon dialogue
évidemment s'il s'agit de je ne sais pas
moi c'est une femme doit dire qu'elle a
connu beaucoup d'hommes dans sa vie on
peut faire une jolie phrase on peut
faire mais si je ne sais pas comment
trouver un exemple mais il ya des
exemples où vraiment il faut essayer de
trouver un geste ou une idée à la place
de dialogue sinon on aura un dialogue
explique dans le cas alors là votre
exemple est très dangereux et évidemment
le cas de la dame qui a donné beaucoup
d'énergie
si elle ne le dit pas comment le montrer
winona rambert oui mais ça pour être
direct sous jouer c'est à dire que ça
pourrait être que justement la fois là
ça pour atlantie phrase qui révélera
davantage à l'effort dans l'antiphrase
aussi mais est ce qu'on peut vous
demander à quoi vous travaillez en ce
moment si vous préparer quelque chose si
on peut le dire ou pas oui c'est andré
mais pas tout à fait tout de suite enfin
la mois de mai l'année prochaine un film
avec jeanne moreau qui sera très très
différent de gym parce que ce sera tirée
d'un roman américain qui s'appelle la
mariée était en noir 20 romans qui est
de 2 qui william irish c'est le premier
roman de william irish a été publié en
1940 en amérique il faut écrire le sénat
de l'adaptation a fait pas fait et non
vers l'adaptation les dialogues en tête
vous savez comment on fait maintenant
pour certains films des prises anglaise
donc il faut faire faire le texte
anglais des gros plans il faut chercher
les endroits parce que ce sont des
endroits naturels très difficile à
trouver parce que ça demande des choses
précises par exemple un atelier de
peintre d'où l'on puisse voir la cour
une course ça ne doit pas deux sur la
rue ça donnait sur une cour que
quelqu'un peut traverser
vous avez peut-être qu'il ya quelques
biens truffaut chez vous voulez pas
parler de vous aujourd'hui parce que
vous vous avez vous est donné pendant
pas mal de temps à ce livre je rappelle
le titre
le cinéma selon hitchcock par françois
truffaut aux éditions robert laffont
merci beaucoup enfin un truc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]